[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to game Sports
III stage we are here with our live show
the lobby which we do most Wednesday's
in San Francisco but we figured we take
the chance do it for live audience here
glad everybody could join good to see
you and of course we will be doing demos
and developer interviews throughout the
week as it continues upon our upstairs
stage and down here I'm your host Mike
McCarty it's good to see everybody I'm
here with Pete Brown as usual hello
Callie Peggy hello and Rob Henry so far
we got like a 90-minute show today and
we will also be having a couple of
guests on later Jake Jake Solomon talk
about the ExComm two chosen War DLC and
Harvey Smith talked about death of the
outsider Dishonored 2 DLC expansion kind
of thing they just announced at the
Bethesda showcase but I want to take the
opportunity to talk to you three about
our favorite games so far I kind of
asked you yesterday but I've got a list
I think first off Pete you played Super
Mario Odyssey I have man that game is
really fun it looks really fun tell us
how it like felt to play it it felt a
lot like you know a mario 64 like any 3d
mario game like when you're actually
just moving Mario on his own but once
you start interacting with the world
things just get very strange very fast
these aren't really like you know
distinct levels you're basically going
around environments finding new
challenges to accomplish now a lot of
them are delightful and weird and
strange so it was just it's surprising
to play the game and just to see like
moment to moment almost like Zelda where
it was like there's one thing I want to
do but then there's like 10 of the
things that capture my attention on the
way there so the Hat seems to be or
Cappy oh yeah the star the show yeah
yeah is there any sort of direction
though like I mean at least Zelda you
have like you know your general main
quest to follow is so there is like a
main quest in each of the little world
that's denoted by like a beacon but the
whole thing is that you're trying to
collect these power moon collectibles to
fuel your ship to go to the next
location so even if you beat that main
objective you may not have enough to go
to the next one so ultimately you'll
have to just explore and do all this fun
stuff anyways but unlike something like
mario 64 like when you get you know the
equivalent of a star you're not actually
like kicked out of the level you just
get to keep going yeah they were talking
about how like you get transported from
place to place they didn't actually show
it but the Odyssey itself is like a ship
right so you can move from place to
place and that's the end of the
structure of the game but yeah it seems
like there's a lot more room
for experimentation with like capturing
things with a cap a little bit
definitely yeah at least in terms of
like how you go about tackling
challenges and solving problems yeah
cool
um did you guys play it at all I did
yeah what do you think of that same
thing yeah I liked it it's poins
actually have au snow so you can buy
like cosmetic items fare ship it's not
like this Safari outfit I bought I
bought a fedora as a laughs only Mario
could pull off a fedora and then I threw
it around a bunch no it's fun I liked it
I saw you could become uh become human
it's really weird man Eva Cage got his
hands and yeah I want to see ya like
Body Snatchers it's weird yeah what's
the value of becoming human
oh there's what there was one point in
new dog city where you can drive an RC
car to get a moon and you have to occupy
this guy's body to do it and I was like
a little weird yeah I wasn't expecting
that from Mario it's do people know
Mario is running around does anyone
acknowledge him or want to talk to him
or like yeah they seemed fine with it
it's straight up like that Simpsons
episode where Homer goes to the real
world yeah they also just like logistics
wives we thought this was gonna come out
they originally announced it holiday or
was it December or something we thought
it was gonna be like later on in the
year I at least assume so I thought it
was just 2017 at some point
yeah October 27th yeah the same day as
Wolfenstein to an assassin's origins
yeah like two weeks after everything
Blue October is pretty packed uh yeah so
Super Mario Odyssey I think seems to be
one of the show stealers so far yeah I
think it's a chance to play it myself
but we showed it on our live stage
upstairs ah another one that we was kind
of rumoured but no one really knew what
it was with Mario Plus Rabbids Kingdom
battle yeah I'm hoping eventually we
could stop say Mario plus rabbits I just
want to say Mario rabbits I actually I'm
really pumped for this game of course it
I love XCOM and we're talking I'm pretty
pumped to have Jake Solomon on the stage
in a little bit but uh yeah Miyamoto
comes out with that gun through smoke
Ubisoft press conference I thought that
was kind of a pleasant surprise uh and
I'm curious how is gonna work overall
because Alex Newhouse one of our writers
he played it and he said it's actually a
lot I mean the
trailer showed off a lot of the tactical
mechanics but he said it's pretty deep
even for like from just might how quirky
it looks yeah he said it was like even
more like XCOM than we all thought it
was watching it okay and I could be
mistaken but I think this comes out the
same day as the chosen war dlc 4x come -
no really I think I could be wrong I'm
really pumped to play both of them
Solomons next our stage right now he's
laughing I don't know but I'm I was one
it was one of my favorite games last
year um I love the the DLC I'm looking
forward to that but I'm also curious to
see like how other developers might take
that kind of a turn-based tactical I
don't think there's like a strategy
layer in this game like there is an X
come where is it be awesome yeah who
knows but I don't know but yeah it's
pretty cool to see other developers for
their take on it I didn't think you'd be
softened intended what combined to do
something like that right
but it's pretty interesting you see like
the creative director when Miyamoto is
on stage just tearing up stallion huh
apparently is like a passion project
that became something big it's on
Nintendo switch coming to it that was
like one of my favorite games of the
show so far
now we've seen I don't really like
Rabbids I'll be honest either go out it
but but I am intrigued yeah yeah looking
forward to probably play it Mike's
looking directly at me yeah I do not
want fest I just don't like rabbits
they're like minions yeah fiends are
pretty awesome come on no no don't ever
talk to me uh yeah anyway and then
moving on past Mario Plus rabbits
Kingdom battle uh Wolfenstein to the new
Colossus we kind of leaked on Amazon
Germany before they announced it
Bethesda press conference this game
looks awesome this shows like an almost
10-minute reveal at Bethesda between
gameplay and cutscenes whatnot would you
get Callie you pretty pumped for this
for you I'm so excited for I thought it
looked fantastic like I loved the UM
like gave me the introduction to the
characters from that opening not trailer
I don't even know what you call it like
it's not a trailer it's not a gameplay
trailer but yeah yeah just seeing like
what this um like what the tone is going
to be I hope they establish that really
well yeah it got me really really pumped
I love alternate history so I'm very
very excited to play this yeah yeah it
feels it feels like they're really
owning yeah yeah I just had alternate
history but also that that one scene was
just so tastefully in life any
ripped from like inglorious basterds
right and yeah the diner in a diner he's
like a strawberry milkshake please well
they did what I bet please they did that
in the new order to with a Frau angle on
the train yeah she was asking I forget
how it went I haven't played that full
game in a while but they've kind of have
a history of doing that we were talking
to the developers yesterday and so the
whole deal is they want to make you know
your enemies they don't want them to
feel stupid because then you don't
really feel that great for overcoming
them right so they want to represent
them as like competent confident people
yeah so I mean who are all so hateful
[ __ ] so yeah you can really stick it
to him but I also feel like yeah you
pulled one over yeah the new Colossus
name is you know like taken from the
poem on the Statue of Liberty but all BJ
blast waste at the end of the first game
also recites it but they showed off on
like New Orleans stuff in the trailer as
well so it's not just like New York
where you would assume I think because
the new Colossus yeah they said New York
they said New Orleans
yeah that's kind of all they would
reveal there's an alligator farm they
just showed that Shiloh is really cool
yeah a couple things I noticed watching
it again he's on like stilts and then
they cut to like the alligator scene um
maybe the still tur like for walking in
the swamp I don't know what else do you
like what have stills for I don't have
no idea the other thing that I am very
excited for is I feel like this time
around there are a handful of characters
that are with you that seemed to be
really well distinguished right at fine
like the guy was like the arm and as
she's delivering some kind of pedagogy
that's the thing with all these quirks
for the guy who's basically dropping
acid well so those two characters so
something insightful that I think
GameInformer picked up on is pretty
positive your choice from the first game
what because those two you have to
choose who survives
oh nice sure so in order for those both
to be in the game I think your choice
from the first game could carry over or
maybe they'll do something like Mass
Effect 3 and 2 did you could do like a
quick thing to choose it before if you
haven't played the first game that's
interesting to see is now before I was
kind of like choosing between the green
horn and the Scottish veteran and now
it's choosing between the cyborgs and
like the druggie so I'm hoping to see
how that it turns out I don't know yeah
but you can also I like that you can
dual wield two separate weapons now it's
the first game it's like are Katie and
how how you got like dual assault rifles
within the first 10 minutes so
apparently that was the bigger technical
challenge for them to overcome for this
game like yeah it sounds like kind of
obvious like why would it be that
difficult but it
he takes a lot of different animation
and physics into account and they were
like no that's it's actually super tough
like new interesting yeah I mean the
earliest incarnation of that for me
before like Halo 2 did it was a
Goldeneye when you had the all guns
cheat on you could have dual wield of
every weapon but if you did like a a and
then za and then took a long time yeah
we're gonna have like as long as the
weapons were next to each other in the
cycle you could actually be using two
different webs like the club and the
sava however you say that things have so
many more like nuanced animations now
not only when you fire but like when you
reload and what you hit when you're
firing and how that reacts like yeah
sure different weapons yeah another one
just looking some in the gameplay too
you can imagine I think there was a like
a freezing type gun or something like
that so if you could imagine like a
flamethrower like a freeze gun like just
like those counter elements would be
really neat
I think I'm not you know it looked like
the laser Kraftwerk I think it was
called is coming back it's like the
electricity laser rifle not sure it's
one of those like alternate history nazi
weapons um I do want to talk about Skull
and Bones another thing that came up
with that Ubisoft conference oh yeah
yeah Kelly you seemed excited by us did
you play a lot of Black Flag no not a
lot of really um I don't know I think
the most notable thing is a lot of
people were talking about I mean we
talked about this on our post show but
um comparing it to see if thieves and
being like how are they gonna compete
and I really think they're for two
different audiences sure um and so I was
really intrigued by like naval battle
specifically in school and bones well
it's also like worth noting I'm pretty
sure skull and bones when see if thieves
finally releasing its full-form I don't
think it's gonna be near each other
either just going on said like 2018 I
think fall yeah and then see if thieves
is in like we we've all I think I played
it like three times by now yeah we're
doing them up on our stage later but uh
yeah like you said though it's two
different very different audiences ones
like a quirky thing from rare where you
it's more communication based this
almost seems like there's some aspects
of for honor in it with the clike
different kinds of ships having
different functions like the Warriors do
in for honor yeah see how that work but
yeah they have said like behind closed
doors that there's gonna be a full
single-player experience with it and you
don't have to be you can meet up with
other people like we are talking Rob
like maybe I could meet up with you and
then we could go and see like a fleet
far in the distance and maybe like okay
they have treasure but it's like six
frigates and we're just too
regular ships and that we probably can't
win that fight and that's what's
interesting to me because I love Black
Flag but not for its Assassin's Creed
aspects for the piracy aspects yeah and
I'm really interested I know Newhouse
saw it Alex at house one of our contract
with Jesus is he an intern not an intern
anymore right you know he said he's that
he wasn't in turn so see editor I think
my bad writer anyways he was a buddy
Alex do you care about this he was
mentioning the wind having a big factor
and he wasn't sure if he liked it or not
but it does seem just like a whole
nother ballgame to focus on just like oh
there's a guy chasing me Lila let me
bounce out yeah make the wrong move
there goes your wind and your momentum
now you're screwed setting sugar yeah so
that seems really cool yeah um and then
anyone move on to something we saw
announced at EA's press conference but
showing off and Microsoft's is anthem
right what do you think about this the
new IP coming from the a team of Bioware
what's right kind of I mean that's why
we're in here right yeah yeah yeah
veterans at Bioware yeah the the
mobility is what has me really stoked
and I hope that will continue to feel
really good as the game goes on and
maybe you know continues to evolve
yeah because exploration is you know it
seems to be a huge part of this game you
know all these like what we go through a
few environments just in this like a 20
30 seconds and it just looks phenomenal
ABI I can't wait to hear more about the
system's involved right you know all the
mechanics have a lineup yeah because I
think it was actually kind of smart that
they showed off the combat and the
navigation rather than maybe like at the
beginning that cutscene was gorgeous
apparently that was in game engine oh
wow
but knowing Bioware I think it was smart
that they showed this stuff off and not
the narrative because we can kind of
trust that they'll have that yeah kind
of like what Phil Spencer was saying
about the Xbox conference he's saying we
could have shown like something from
Halo 6 we want so we could have shown
Gears 5 we wanted to know we're gonna
have that so why waste time doing that
I'm actually this was awesome to
scuba-diving that you could just go
underwater immediately Rob like I
remember you were watching that when it
happened and you're like what is going
on I was swearing like come on it looks
great yeah that's such a cool idea just
nosedive yeah in the long run I'm
curious like I said how cuz I you know
like a lot of people are saying that saw
more of it or at least talk to
Bioware Microsoft or not sorry Bioware
about it they said there is definitely a
narrative at play it's not just gonna be
trying to be destiny although it isn't
that space destiny the division you know
massive multiplayer games I guess
apparently like Beyond Good and Evil 2
is more of an MMO we've heard a lot of
weird things about that and I guess
that's the separate thing
I don't know I didn't really put Beyond
Good and Evil 2 on here because I don't
I'm not that excited for it it was cool
that they showed it 15 years after the
first game came out but anyway um one
thing a lot of people brought up Shadow
the Colossus on ps4 had total surprise
not even just like a simple reskin it's
like oh no yeah apparently yeah I mean
you can just tell but I almost
everything about it is brand-new as far
as I can tell right yeah they've
maintained like sort of the with the
animations work and like you know the
movement and stuff like that obviously
the tone and like the Colossus but
everything just looks brand-new
yeah the firaon some of these guys you
know the depth of field of the motion
blur like all of that is is it really
adds to the scale the sense of scale
that's going on here I'm curious if
they'll update the controls at all
there's something there well because
they were finding you know like through
rose-tinted glasses I love this game but
when I do go back to plant even the Pete
Bob ps3 eco collection yeah amigo
collection its kind of controls are not
the tightest I'm sure the camera is
gonna be worked on I mean those these
games have you know wait as games are
like that or they're a bit floaty and
odd yeah maybe the gyroscope you come
into play to help with some of the
aiming and stuff from horshack like that
might yeah especially when you're on a
girl I remember it being kind of like
you're fighting the controls of this so
I'm assuming they wouldn't do a pass
over this without doing that kind of
stuff I feel like we'll see on every
Sony generation from here on out and I'm
fine with it yeah yeah I I never played
it so oh [ __ ] I'm excited to have like
an opportunity to play it yeah god it's
so good I was excited with it uh gone
Luke are our TD upstairs the first shot
of the castle and it's really exciting
to see how much excitement is actually
in that room and he's just like yeah
it's like what you're crazy but he knew
that castle so well yeah
first frame not getting phenomenal
yeah I played it back I think I got a
unreleased a back one up before I was
like in tune with the constant flow of
games coming out and I didn't really
know what it was I never played eco I
forget how old I was when she lost came
out but I just remember playing it I was
like what is this it's all boss fights
and it's just like this really silent
world the most like life you'll see is
your horse or those lizards right fine
for to upgrade I I didn't even know
those existed when I first played I'd
kill any of them I just had the same
health and endurance the whole time what
do you know about it what do I know
about it yeah you kind of said it I mean
the other thing I do know is that it's
the same creators of last our last
Guardian yeah and I don't really like
that game so that's and that's how I
heard about these games to be honest
it's like I really enjoyed last Guardian
and and it's like oh it's a combination
of some ago in Last Guardian right it's
not completely right it's not completely
right but subito ADA is the guy who's
kind of the conceptual genius behind all
this stuff yeah aren't there like I want
don't want say Easter eggs but like
narrative ties at all or is that just
that went like theorized okay no Pixar
shared universe Tarantino kind of thing
right I don't know if there's any direct
nods but yeah I love that game the one
kalasa Colossus that stands out to me is
I it's a lake and there's a platform in
the middle when you finally find them
cuz like half the game is finding them
and right hold up your sword and the
light shines to the next one yeah and
then the story unfolds in a cool way and
obviously I won't spoil if you guys have
played you should experience it yourself
good if you haven't no but you it's like
a bird over the lake and in order to
like get on to him it's it's unreal it's
it's fantastic yeah okay alright you
know tell you how we're gonna play it is
very sick and it's really excited again
we don't have much b-roll of at all
aside from like the logo menu screen
coming up is metroid prime for and i
also want to talk about how they brought
this up during the conference it was
just like sandwiched between a new yoshi
gained a new kirby I think Emily was a
they did that like Pokemon announcement
they like a guy behind his desk is like
yes there's a new Pokemon casually
saying there's a new like switch
exclusive Pokemon RPG right which you
freaked out about yeah and it was so
casuals like oh you know for the first
time in the consoles 20 year history or
the series 20 years history yeah on
akkad consoles but it's like so casual
like I was like excuse me what okay I
think I screamed good yeah I mean I'm
very excited
don't know anything about it casual it
was like half our Nintendo Direct
supposed to what Microsoft Day like an
hour-and-a-half conference Microsoft
went over an hour and a half and it was
Ray that was a great conference not
taking away from them but Nintendo just
like rifled through things I feel sure
it didn't because you were left
wondering about like wait what did they
just announced what not gonna be and
then meanwhile they're casually Pokemon
switch that shrek prime for is coming
out and then even like afterwards yeah
oh yeah right there's a wrap I guess
we're looking over your impressions for
Mario and you're like what they're still
going with the other Metroid yeah it was
interesting at first cuz I saw the four
come up and it didn't register right
away cuz none of the original trilogy
had numbers it was just Metroid Prime
echoes corruption and the original one
obviously didn't wasn't called Metroid
Prime 1 but yeah but it came up and this
is for a number of title now but I did
you you all play the Metroid Prime games
yeah
the first two I didn't play a crook for
options like my favorite one actually
you've despite the fact that it's we you
like motion controller sorry Wow
weary motion guys um did you think I
make it better they aiming yeah oddly
enough cuz I mean going from a GameCube
controller to that it was kind of like a
res evil 4 on the Wii I actually really
liked and I would tell you to play it
like that because of aiming again
yeah because um the c-stick on the
gamecube is not arresting to aim with
despite the fact that I played like
timesplitters to a lot on the Gamecube
um but yeah my try Prime's really good
game yeah really good yeah it's long -
takes a while to get through but I mean
him you played but wait it you keep
looking at me cuz you keep trying to ask
me here though I unfortunately haven't I
never Ed quiet you yeah I know I know it
man it adapts the the things that made a
2d Metroid great into 3d and then with
that comes a whole new layer of
immersion yeah and like new puzzles and
creativity it's so even at the time like
it was really great but it today Petra
at prime is still an amazing game it
does hold up well I played it like over
Christmas when I was home on my Gamecube
and it's really good and then they have
the collection right on we II yeah the
trilogy cool I never played those I'm
assuming they updated that can run in
echoes the confessions they did and it's
also on Wii U you can download it oh
cool yeah but presumably I'm they'd be
dumb not to bring it to switch right in
some form well once Virtual Console
stuff gets figured out
that what happened Raja we'll see I I
think it is notable that metroid prime 4
is not retro like it's not retro studios
right it is yeah that's a big dope
so what's not know oh I thought they
said it was oh it's it's a new young
team yeah oh we don't know if that's
internal or not yes that I'm curious
about that like I'm I'm intrigued
obviously because of the prime name yeah
but I would want to see more from the
game because it's not the same studio
sure not that a new studio can't do a
good job
I just wrote when I like save my
excitement for a gameplay reveal we can
get excited for now well yeah yeah but
you know I didn't say I wasn't excited I
don't like knock it over hi I'm just
green with you totally but then then
it's also the question what is retro
doing if not this right yeah well yeah
one thing I don't have like we didn't
mention in our list I just want to bring
up quick is also after during the
treehouse live they announced mercury
steam who did castlevania lords of
shadow 100 and mirror of fate right 3d
ass game which i thought was all right
ok yeah it's like 2.5 they called it
like a Shadow Complex almost maybe but
anyway they're making samus Returns
which is a reimagining of return of
Samus Metroid 2 it's coming out soon oh
there's beer all sweet umm yeah we have
this on the stage we just did actually
before if you're if you've been watching
our stream all day we just had on this
yeah it looks really good yeah it's
interesting they're adding like melee
which is not a thing
yeah and if you time it properly you get
a like charge blast from your your arm
cannon the girl playing from tree house
was awesome yeah cool I'm like worried
that I'm of course they pick someone
who's good at game but I was like shame
she's timing this perfectly good they
showed off the little Metroid amiibo
yeah it's squishy
Yoshi's woolly world one was also like
yah yeah hurry did I say that right
Yoshi's woolly world yeah what's yarny
that doesn't make sense it was wooly it
will ish it was heavy no parties it was
yard it's yarn Yoshi yeah I were right
like that texture so we were right Yoshi
I'll oh I am I am buying that squishy
Metroid amiibo so hard yeah you can
already preorder it yeah I'm getting it
it's gonna be funny and not to just
throw this to another outlet but I'm
looking forward to Griffon if you guys
watch amiibo correctly 40m trying to put
that in his mouth how I want
to do the Guardian the yeah she's also
yes also through yeah there's also the
Zelda ballot of the champions right
second guilty time and that's all
there's for amiibo for them that's
awesome
yeah I'm not a me bow person I don't
like go crazy over my bozell the ones my
desk in San Francisco but there was a
Levin new amiibo now's 83 chip and four
of them driving them with bad Zelda is
one champions those are pretty good so
the four champions the two for Metroid 3
for Mario Odyssey and then two for the
remaster of Mario Luigi superstar saga
damn yeah awesome
I'm up yeah and then I do wanna move on
to rob I think your game the show so far
that you played that'll get it to o
battlefront - yeah played like a solid
hour maybe a little more yeah at right
after EA's press conference right or
before yeah yeah ah yes right tell me
about it I love it what you play I mean
I'm real excited for resident pilot sure
I was the I love flying planes and
spaceships um and that was one of the
biggest gripes I had with the previous
game was that you know you weren't able
to roll manual roll your plane had those
like quick - quick flip quick side rolls
in order to like disengage from a
lock-on or anything like that there was
that was the biggest surprise was like
Kenny I didn't expect it like getting
into a Naboo Starfighter and then was
like oh my god I'm rolling oh my god
and so you're doing tight turns you're
able to like really have fun uh and
function as a pilot because the end the
biggest gripe is you know you're doing a
flip and you're doing a nosedive and I
need to pull away um you know I need to
go flip under well now I'm upside down
yeah my arms tied up but now much they
wrote so the game's like well we got to
autocorrect you you lose all control and
it's a mess um but here yeah you can you
can um manual roll and we talked with
the developers of the game and delta T
also because it's tough you know you you
don't want to make flying too difficult
or too intimidating so there are
functions they they clarify that you
know you can make the games or the
flight controls simplify yeah it kind of
were in the previous game but other than
that the class space stuff is like very
much needed no longer are you just kind
of winging it on the field hoping you'll
find any kind of power up maybe a hero
or a weapon yeah those are now isolated
so you also can like look
at a player like most games you would
you know you want to have some
predictability factor in there like
alright this is a this is a heavy guy
with a like a heavy machine gun laser uh
I know what he's packing for the most
part so it's nice to have that change I
remember playing battlefield one last
year in October when it came out because
that battlefront one from dice was I
think November of 2015 I remember
playing battlefield one and wishing that
they had done more of a shooter with
battlefront 1/9 of enlike hoping that
maybe battlefield ones mechanics would
seep into battlefront too and it kind of
seems like that's the case not as deep
sure it's still for Star Wars fans but I
think there's more of an actual game
here under the Star Wars which I don't
think the first game had now you like
you can really feel these guns as far as
like oh this is a very much a light SMG
type that's going to do low fire damage
yeah or like the snipers have like long
cooldowns which again the active reload
is really neat we're like that was
present in the last game we're like you
know I think each gun had a different
kind of meter to time but now there's
like the yellow which will get you that
quicker reload obviously if you hit the
red you're gonna have a longer reload as
a punishment factor then there's the
green which can be like a damage boost
or like maybe like a high fire rate
where you just have no know what you
call it like was it cool down excuse me
out right like yeah I'm just gonna like
hammer out he's like lasers I love it
but overall it seems like it improved on
the first game so far from where he
played no story yeah it's just this one
mode one one map the map looks gorgeous
like yes see it was smart because you
know again they're doing all three eras
yeah and this was just exciting nice to
see you again because you know sir say
what you will about Phantom Menace like
there's something about there's what
about battle droids and just the Clone
Army it's like it's great it's a really
gorgeous look at City the coolest part
about the sequels to me
we're the only cool part was the action
military stuff in the actual yeah um and
then you saw Darth Maul you played han
Solo the heroes did you revamp the
battle point system obviously but you
played a Darth Maul and Han Solo and Rey
it was kind of funny during the EI
things they're like oh here's ray she's
really she's badass and that not his
eyes or does she Darth Maul's just
there's no screwing yeah well each a
kind
had this in the previous game where's
like when you played as Leia she was
very much like a support hero or she
would like lay down like shields and I
think even in like health drops yeah
Maul is very much your frontline choking
people out force push barrels with his
double lightsaber but Rey apparently has
like pretty neat tricks which she could
like Mindwarp you so your controls yeah
as her enemy will like get all screwed
up but she could also um I've heard
these names but she can she kind of has
that like radar scan so she can like
point out enemy troops like you know
spot them on your HUD whether it be
scanning I forget what it looks like but
again you know you're also very much
reserved with these heroes and the
previous game like you know you see I
always say like you see Luke Skywalker
from like miles out you are still
running away from them because he's
hopping towards you it's like a Monty
Python the holy grail when Lancelot's
sprinting at him dad it was back then uh
but now it's sorry now they're easier to
take down I if I see like a hero like I
can get some shots off I'll probably die
but as a team you want to take them down
yeah yeah uh any other thoughts on Belle
front - I think the battle point system
is really smart sherry I want to talk
about that again cuz like that rather
than tokens kind of earning sort of like
killstreaks
I think it's a really good way to update
the multiplayer so I'm excited about
that definitely and that's another
aspect that seems more tailor-made to
shooters yeah just a Star Wars game like
for the sake of being layout randomly
yeah and just a via the bow point system
is probably the biggest thing takeaway
because again in the game it's like you
know your team you want to have rolls
yeah you can get into four-person squads
but the other thing is like okay if I
want to be a pilot yeah like I can I can
focus on that opposed to like rushing
across the battlefield and getting like
killed chasing for an x-wing token like
it's one of the first things you get so
if I get only just a couple kills on the
field that's that's something I can
generally get into quick yeah I want to
focus on the hero stuff I'll have to
risk it and then get like 5000 and yeah
absolutely it's fun to see I do want to
bring up one last game before we get our
guests on even within two I'm actually
pretty excited for because the first
game under changing economy and tango
gameworks I had a lot of potential back
in 2014 but I think there's 15 chapters
and I remember loving the first 10
it felt like Reza before kind of at its
best moments it felt like the beginning
of resident 4 or 5 when you're in that
village and kind of running around
surviving and using the tools that you
have at your disposal to your advantage
but then the last five chapters of evil
then my opinion became you know there's
a turret sequence the final boss fight
overhaul correctly you're like avoiding
this giant person just giant eyeballs
like gaze as your it was like a mini
game almost and I think the last five
chapters had really bad pacing issues
yeah
but evil then - I'm curious like how
they'll build on the first game yes I
talked to Pete Hines with Lucy James on
our demo stage yesterday and he's
talking about how one of the things
they're going into this game thinking
about is how to pace it so there's like
points of respite for the player so not
always having like super grotesque
enemies or jump scares but like having
just moments of tension where it's a
little bit of a breather but without
letting go of that horror element sure
so I think there I'm I mean from what he
told us it sounds like they're putting a
little more emphasis on improving the
pacing yeah which was an issue with the
first one so right um I think if you
learn the mistakes for your first game
like I'm very excited to play your
second game you know definitely I would
love to see I just Mikami and the people
that he like mentors doing their thing
in a future cool any last minute ones
before right
yeah yeah I'm really excited for
undertale on ps4 oh right yeah I still
don't
oh yeah I haven't played undertale I'm
sorry hi-oh
undertale I know I should undertale
just so phenomenal I I and it's one of
those I didn't expect it to come to
anything besides PC because of the way
the saves work yeah I'm just really
excited to see that and the collector's
edition is gorgeous yeah and I'll
absolutely be buying it I think Toby Fox
just knocked it out of the park with
yeah the earthbound inspired RPG
self-aware oh yeah I'm looking forward
to playing it for the first time on ps4
but uh unfortunately Rob handler II I'm
gonna have to kick you off that's cool I
got another point yeah I got cancer is
gonna call get off this thing where do I
go alright bye everyone
there dude uh we are bringing Jake
Solomon from four exes onto the stage
we're gonna talk about XCOM to war the
chosen and here he is right now
um yeah but we are just the TLC was
announced the expansion Jake how you
doing hi everybody
ah the only thing that's louder than I
thought I'm sorry hi everybody
yeah it's take some adjusting but I yeah
check one check check
good good all right I figured so uh big
news from yesterday on the would PC
gaming show was that yesterday I'm yeah
oh I don't don't ask me huh was it
yesterday day before a different foreign
a gift for yesterday yep yeah yeah War
of the chosen X come to is biggest
expansion to date right yeah it's big
it's very very big it's um it's I'm
trying to think of another word than big
right now it's huge it's met massive
gigantic its bursting its has a bad
that's not good girthy yeah oh my god
what uh yeah
yes comprehensive best better thank you
yeah I don't want to sound like too much
of a kiss-ass but XCOM to is one of my
favorite game yes I would I think we
shuttle oh that's okay
continue ah it's going every lobby is
genius no but uh yeah I'm excited for
this and actually I missed it because we
were watching something else like during
the PC game show I was hosting something
upstairs and then I got off and I came
down I got the stage and then I came
down to catch up on it it looks really
great um but it looks huge because the
last I think the biggest one for two
safar was Shen's last gift right yeah we
had a couple of DLCs and then this one
is it's not you know it's it's an
expansion it's huge you know we have a
lot of ton of new enemies we have three
new soldier classes we've got all kinds
of toys for the player to engage with
it's just really big tons of systems
like I lost my voice in the first day
because I was trying to explain the
whole thing to people and then my
spelling right now I have to like hit
high points and just hope people trust
that it's it's really really big yeah um
would it be fair to compare it to a the
evil within Wow
no [ __ ] all right what not at all it's
experimental
oh my god enemy within retreat which
pretty much would not answer long week
oh yeah but yeah you're right enemy
offense oh yeah it's it's like it's it's
much much bigger even than enemy within
it it's huge it's huge um and so you
know we
have these these chose and these
handsome handsome aliens there and so
they're like these in there she is huh
she's lovely they're these that they're
kind of like the ultimate enemy of X
common so they're like the player in the
sense that the players going to fight
them multiple times with of course the
game and every time they do the chosen
are going to get stronger they're going
to gain they procedurally gained new
strengths and new weaknesses and so
maybe one time you come in to fight the
assassin you think you know she's going
to work but instead now she's completely
immune to melee and you're like okay I
just lost my ability to attack her that
way and so it just forces the player to
sort of rethink things every time they
face them that's awesome it reminds me a
little bit of the Nemesis system sort of
maybe not as like deeps Nemesis system
order kind of befores yes yeah I mean
that was definitely the inspiration
absolutely um you know we thought
certainly that the ability to have those
procedural strengths and our characters
are more fixed but having we've never
had enemies with actual personality
before and so that's one of the big
things we wanted to do here was add a
lot of characters with personality and
so they always play procedurally it's
still very much XCOM but they all
personalized they'll talk to you when
you're fighting them about how you did
against them last time how the other
chosen are doing big things you've done
throughout the game and then they'll
talk to you outside of combat as well
and it's the same thing with the
factions these are the new sort of new
resistance movements the player can
integrate with they have leaders and
those leaders are characters and they'll
be talking to you about things that are
going as well so it's very lively and
even to the point where we have on your
on the dropship back from missions you
know you'll hear like the radio from the
Advent the government and they'll be
trying to spin what you just did I know
for them like I know nobody worried it
was no big deal nobody got hurt just a
gas explosion or something and then in
the base when you go into the bar
we actually have Jake Busey on people
you know Jake Busey is Gary Busey's
amazing son and he's our radio
resistance DJ and so he'll be in there
and he's like spinning thing for the
resistance so there's just a lot of
voices and a lot of characters that are
they all respond to the things that
you're doing and so it really feels like
okay this is a real resistance movement
people are responding to it it feels
a live world you go more into the like
how you build the relationships with the
resistance factions because like in the
trailer it says like problem is that
they all hate each other that's right
like you're kind of seems like it's
almost like city-state relationships to
talk about civilization yeah yeah you
you have to win them over and so yeah
they have very different philosophies
all these different factions have
different philosophies and you need to
win them over and the way you do that is
that each faction is kind of paired off
against one of these chosen and so to
win over the factions you kinda have to
go after the chosen that they don't like
and then eventually you can recruit
their soldiers which are very very
powerful units you can have more control
over their faction you can start telling
them what to do and so it's a really
it's another really in-depth system
that's totally new for people who get
really geeky about it like me can you go
a little more in-depth on the three oh
yes I can you need that's like kinda I'm
never afraid to go geeky yeah you know
that's it
that's what I do um yeah so you've got
one faction it's they're called the
Reapers and they are stealth marksmen
and they're saboteurs so they can attack
yeah there you go there's a Reaper um so
they can attack from concealment and
there's always a chance that they won't
be considered will be revealed every
time you attack you'll actually see like
a meter rolling and be like oh you
stayed concealed okay and so it's always
this big trade-off of do I really want
to you know they're a great Scout unit
but they're also really deadly so you
kind of trade that off and then there's
a skirmish er which is there defectors
from the alien army that actually join
XCOM and so they're they're half alien
half soldier hybrids and they're
skirmisher look at the nails see you can
tell by the hackles that's not human
it's not human um but it needs to get
that touch stuff but yeah so they
they're really powerful they take a lot
of actions every turn and so they get an
extra action if somebody attacks them
they even have an ability called battle
Lord which if they trigger it then every
time an AI unit takes an action thus
kirmser gets an act how cool they can
take like ten actions in one single turn
they're crazy and then the final group
is called the Templars and they're this
melee only class and they have these big
psionic blades there we go there's the
Templars and they're cool because they
build up power every time they attack
they build up power and
they can unleash it with their really
powerful ability so there's this
trade-off of building up power and then
wanting to keep it because it makes
their attacks more deadly or you can
unleash it in these really big powerful
attacks well for me I'm an ex-con newbie
I'm such a baby
welcome I don't know any I don't know
much about it I do love strategy though
this don't thing I can jump into or
should I start off on just base game no
no you can definitely jump into this
because this integrates completely with
the base game I mean what we've done is
we've added a bunch of new narrative
we've added all this stuff but it
actually sits on top and integrates into
the base game and so you know we've got
a new intro cinematic we've got a new
finale we got all the cinematic stuff
that adds in we got all this gameplay
stuff that ends in but yeah you can just
jump right in and and get going ok cuz I
think Michael want me to play this I
want to check it out yeah for sure that
I can jump straight into it I'll do it
so got it every day yeah oh god I'm not
joking we need an ex-con jar where he
puts a dollar in every time he brings it
up yeah I did not tell them to say this
I promise uh yeah I'm curious
so someone myself who's played a lot and
I want to go into like mods if you don't
mind a little bit outside of the dlc
because I've been playing the long war
pretty regular long war too regularly I
have since it came out yeah you are for
real yeah I'm a masochist I look I can't
make it past a mission and that yeah I'm
just like oh this is for real yeah well
I haven't beaten it yeah whatever
running a lot of it I don't you know
like you only beat XCOM X come to broad
a lot but I'm curious what um
the chosen war is gonna do to like the
overall flow of XCOM - right like what
does it mean for like you know you said
you go to the bar and you've got a new
character there that's kind of like
doing the propaganda stuff on both sides
Advent and resistance yeah and I'm
curious what like if I'm someone who's
played a lot of X come - yeah chose more
when I jump into it outside of these
like these three factions and you know
like all the added layers with these
bosses what is gonna be like for the
overall like identity of it it's very
it's very different I mean so we have
all these small systems that change that
we've changed research we change so your
soldiers now they get fatigued and so if
they go on multiple missions even if
they're not wounded they're going to get
tired and what that means is that you're
going to start rotating a lot more
soldiers through the game is much
longer because of all this extra content
one of the cool things is that you
soldiers can now gain negative traits
which are like personality quirks okay
and so they get really wounded you know
one of the funnier ones is the obsessive
and that means that that soldier if
they're running around and the gun isn't
fully loaded instead of doing what you
tell them to do they'll instead they'll
reload and so it sounds like me right so
you have you have this big tactic you
want to pull off maybe like move over
here and they'll mover there then be
like oh my guns not load and they'll
reload and you're like ah crap you know
and so it creates these these
personality quirks with your soldiers
and so there's a lot of these little
elements that just really change the way
that the game used to work and it's it's
a longer game you have a lot more Souls
you have these heroes they're all these
new strategy systems interacting with
the factions there's a lot of fun stuff
like there's a daily there's a
propaganda mode so every time you win a
mission what it's going to do is take
your soldiers and it's going to put them
together and pose them in a bunch of
different poses and generate like a
motto for this squad and then it'll put
filters over it and you can you can
adjust everything you can type in what
texts you want you can rotate your
soldiers give them from a bunch of
different poses and so you sort of take
this like group selfie after the mission
take a picture and then that poster
starts appearing throughout the world on
the sides of buildings and and so
there's there's just on the fun side of
things there's a challenge mode so you
can jump in and play a sort of like
challenge that it's you got thirty
minutes you got one time to beat it and
then you're ranked against everybody
else in the world and there's these
really difficult challenge so if you
just want to play a little bit of XCOM
so yeah there's just there's just tons
and tons of stuff yeah that's awesome
because it's kind of hard to explain to
people outside of XCOM that there
actually is a little despite the fact
that it's like this pretty hardcore
strategy title there's a lot of
personality to it like I remember some
of my favorite like snipers and granted
ears from XCOM to more than I do in like
narrative games yeah and I like this
stuff because I feel like it'll increase
my connection to this world into these
characters that's right I don't know if
that's the aim for that that's
absolutely the aim there's two sides of
story it's a story that you know the
dictated like narrative cinematic story
we certainly have added to that but
really the stuff that six of you as
players is your own moments and being
able to share those and so we have
something called soldier pawn
which leans into that the idea is that
soldiers form relationships with each
other now and so now soldiers have
compatibility with other soldiers you
take them on missions and you'll find
out hey these two are really compatible
and if they go on multiple missions
together they'll form a bond and that
means when they go on missions together
they get a bunch of free abilities that
are all about their bond and so it just
sort of creates a new story like oh
these two guys they love each other and
these two over here they're they bond it
together and they're really powerful
when they're together so it sort of
feeds him that you have like the player
driven story that inspired by Fire
Emblem yeah yeah yeah I mean you will
not be able to bring your kids back from
the future I we have I don't we don't
yet have that technology
oh but yeah I mean I always I always
loved that about firing them it just
makes sense you know in your head you're
already forming these relationships
losing characters and so you know just
sort of was a natural thing to do yeah
yeah and I'm curious actually
speaking of like long war - have you
been talking to the team that did that
and like how that's gonna affect or how
the DLC might affect that I haven't I
haven't talked to those guys yet oh
that's that's on my list of things but
yeah I didn't want I was talking to pee
before the show about like like mods and
how you can go about creating them and
obviously the week the long war is
probably the one that arose out of you
the most and that's the most you know
the famous one that came out and I
played a lot I played like a long war -
a lot and you've always been really
vocal that you love supporting the
modding community talk about I guess
like in broad terms what the mati
community has done for XCOM -
specifically I mean it's amazing so I
think that it's this idea and there are
some Studios like this and where you
when you realize that if I'm a creative
director my team we're not the owners of
the game or the game experience like it
is especially once you have a number
after your name in the in the game that
means that the only reason you exist is
because there's an audience the audience
owns the game I'm not going to go off
and make something that the audience
doesn't like you know they're they're
more owners of the game than and then
any of us are and mods are the ultimate
extension of that we're members your
audience are actually creating content
and they can serve people may have I
want this specific thing like long war
we exhales not hard enough we wanted
even more
we want more complex and so to allow
your audience to sort of be part of the
creative process like that's a gift
because we can't make that much content
nobody can and and you can cater to very
specific parts of your audience you can
create all this content you can get
direct feedback from people it's it's
amazing so I'm so glad that it's worked
out like the modding is it's a very big
part of what XCOM is yeah I think some
of my favourite mods are kind of minor
as well like having the halo weapons in
the game right that's really right yeah
or like Star Wars that's right uh Bob
Ross mod is pretty strong Oh Bob Oh it
is amazing explain this to me what is
amazing it's you get you have Bob Ross
you have the model it's it's Bob Ross
he's got his hair and then voice lines
from barber and like actual lines from
Bob Ross oh he'll be like oh isn't that
a pretty little and he'll be like guys
I'm gonna be like that's a beautiful
thing thank you like it's just amazing
and so in those are moments where like
obviously probably for legal reasons I
could have nothing to do with that but
um but you watch that and you're just
like I've got to try that I've got to
play that so yeah it's amazing and so
there's the funny mods there's a serious
mods there's the purely cosmetic mods
it's just really amazing stuff yeah and
if you don't mind me saying I think
there are mods that make your game
better maybe things yeah oh my god the
evac all think that was like a minor one
so when you're trying to like evac
troops from a dropship you used to have
to uh yeah you they were not kidding you
are hardcore
yeah ok yeah no you used to have to like
go clean one evac Hameed take even
rappel up to it
but then of course there's evac also
they would all just go through once
you're in the zone of the dropship but
like what's it like seeing modders like
like I said it sounds like you're open
to the idea that they base your course
yeah we don't think that we can't tell
people we've made the perfect game every
time we make it we don't believe that
and so it's nice again mining is great
because if all of a sudden there's this
hey the audience really doesn't like
this so they think this would make it
better people can use our tools go out
there and be like we made it for you and
then we can play and be like that's
amazing like we integrate stuff from
mods like we look at them and we improve
on it now since you're so hardcore I
will tell you we now have the ability to
as you're moving your mouth as you move
the curve
turn around if you hold down the Alt key
it will show you a preview of like what
are the targeting options at that
location Oh second so that's super nice
really and that was inspired by some
mods pushed what we did further and we
said okay we'll go even further than
that and it just it's a great symbiotic
relationship yeah I've got people I've
got friends who play XCOM - and it's a
question I want to ask you is do does
the like vast the amount of mods in the
war in the XCOM - community diminish the
the impact of like pay DLC when you can
play these mods for free I don't think
so I mean I think that what mods do is
that keep people engaged and they change
it up and they keep it fresh for people
and then we can come along and do things
that other people can you know we can
create certain types of content certain
types of gameplay that you know we hope
we can add value that others can't but
for us we see the mods is it's a great
way of saying like ok the community gets
all this new content that they can
engage with and then we can come in that
gives us a time you know it took us a
while to make this product it took so
long to make something this big it took
us our entire team it took us a long
time and and thank God for mods that can
keep people excited and playing and then
we can come in later and say alright now
we have this massive thing that you know
modders can't do and then we release it
to people and I think everybody gets
reenergized and then people are just
going to go and mod the expansion pack
yeah um and then I think we did an
interview with you recently if I'm not
mistaken or like a couple months ago we
asked you like at a certain point does
the game stop becoming the developers
and almost become fans like how do you
balance implementing fan feedback with
like the authorial intent on your side
yeah and that's the balance is that even
if your audience they're not designers
but they are the owners in my opinion
their values are more important than
mine I'm not gonna I'm not going to
force try to force my values on players
because if I do that then I won't be in
this job very long so I listen to what
they say and I say ok I'm the designer I
should have the tools to implement what
they want you know you know so they tell
me I don't like this or this parts
creator we wish we had more of that well
then it's my job to say ok my job my
training should allow me to say like I
know how to implement that and so that's
what that's
it's led to a lot of the things in the
expansion pack is saying like okay we've
heard what people love about ex-con to
what they want what they want improved
and so let's go out there make something
massive it sort of delivers on that if
enough people got in your ear is there
ever a chance we could see ex-con come
to Nintendo switch um yeah as a player I
would love that I can say with all
honesty I have not had that conversation
yet but yeah I definitely seen the
valley that for sure all right we got
Mario and rabbits ask you about that I
know but I just you know I see if I see
an opportunity for something that would
work great with a touch screen in some
respects absolutely absolutely know that
that's absolutely true
I mean we've certainly had success on
touch screens with um enemy Unknown so
yeah what do you think of Mario +
rabbits battling them I mean I could I
wish I wish somebody had a camera on me
as I was watching press conference I was
like I was like oh cool yeah and that
was like what like what what is that was
like what are they doing and then
there's like some point where I think
some guy was like and as you see a Luigi
how stick in half Guevara and I was like
ha ha what world am i in i seriously
have had a stroke um so it Sam it I mean
it is amazing to me it's really really
cool
I think what they've done is really cool
I mean it like just seeing it is very
exciting I love the look of it and it
for me it's fun I cannot play
XCOM with my daughters in fact so I have
three daughters seven four and one and
so the other day when I was on the PC
gaming show my wife was like eh let's
watch daddy on it on the show and I
forgot to tell like the trailer is going
to be on before I come on and it's just
all these scary like you know my
daughter's like oh geez I don't let them
watch XCOM and so I see this and I'm
like hey there's something that's
turn-based its tactical it's not X
comments they're a completely new thing
but there are similarities there and I'm
like I can actually like play something
and I could be like hey daddy does
something kind of like this you know and
so I can have that experience with them
so for me it's awesome you see the fact
that maybe since it was on Nintendo
sorry Ubisoft stage but Nintendo's
involved the fact that like now Mario is
getting into this kind of
genre like subjective strategy yeah you
know Fire Emblem is another comparison
yeah do you see this as a promising kind
of maybe spark for other teams to make
games like this unquestionably I mean we
all we all build off of each other you
know everything every time I play a game
you know everything I do I'm sitting
there going like how can I use this how
can I use this and so it's great I mean
is is going to bring more fans to
tactical gameplay and so yeah I mean
yeah it's it's so awesome to see it's so
awesome to say so yeah I think it's for
me it's exciting I think it's it's
validating when you make and you know
turn-based tactics to see some other
Studios trying it out and adding their
own spin on things so it's it's really
exciting did you see anything else from
whether as an intent oh you be soft or
anything that excited you you get to
watch the press conferences yeah yeah I
mean Battlefront
like the single-player portion of it
like you know like that's really really
exciting for me I'm a super Star Wars
nerd um yeah anthem I think anthem in
pembaur does anything that's the kind of
studio that I'll be like okay I will
definitely play that you know I just EVC
like the Bioware logo and I'm like yeah
and I'll buy that I'll play that um so
yeah I mean I think those were two that
I was super excited about last night
looks pretty crazy um looked really cool
so yeah I mean I love I love you 3 I
mean I'm I'm a gamer I love you 3 I'm
not cynical about it like I get so
excited seeing what people are making
like it's just as exciting yeah more
personal side uh going back to XCOM as
you can imagine after I've been talking
about it I actually know a deal like a
decent deal about how XCOM in 2012
became a thing you know not easy no what
is it like now that X calms down the
world XCOM 2 and you're just like
pushing out dlc now those expansions
like Nintendo Ubisoft we're kind of
getting into that kind of game what does
it feel like to go from the struggle
that was to bring XCOM 2012 to life to
now I mean it's very different I mean
it's very different and I'm very very
grateful I mean because the thing to
remember is that what we do it's it's
very like you know what did you do last
I mean we all know like your your first
bad game is probably your last one and
so I just sort of keep that present and
I think our team we stay hung
and we get excited by what other people
are doing and all of us we went through
that and it was hard and then we got to
a point like this but we still remember
like we just need to worry about like
making sure we're always making a good
game and that's what always comes down
to you always got to make a good game so
yeah it's it but it is rewarding it's
it's super wording look around and see
more turn-based tactical games and
seeing that becoming a bigger deal like
that's it's pretty cool do you get the
chance to play any fire emblems much of
them oh yeah I mean yeah and and I think
that that's really inspiring I mean they
do completely different things to do
they do damage types they do they did
the relationship stuff and so yeah I
mean you get you feed off of those kinds
of games you feed off of I'm playing
persona right now like in my hotel room
I brought my ps4 and it was like hey you
gonna party man I'm like are you kidding
me
like yeah I have three young kids of
ours to steal I said my ps4 so I wake up
in the morning I play persona I go to
bed at night playing for Sona like I'm
like just and I did that to me is like
the dream of e3 it's not the parties
it's like being in a hotel and just
playing video games but uh where are you
in the game without spoiling too very
early I'm very er I'm still attacking
the first castle so happy - yeah there's
a guy in the pink underwear in the robot
I'm having a hard time parsing uh what
I'm seeing sometimes and some of the
enemies get pretty graphic yeah later on
if you haven't seen him yet I think you
know what I'm talking about if you have
but I don't think I don't think I mean
I've seen some strange once where I'm
like I'm not sure what I'm yeah I'm
looking at there but yeah that's that's
a joy that's right of the joy of it
you're just like wow this is yeah yep
so you are like you know it for access
itself between civilization the recent
civil'zation 6 and I've come to and
going back in your development history
you've been very I think it's fair to
say focused on the PC development but no
ex-con has come to consoles yeah last
generation with XCOM and enemy within
not evil within but within what's also
on getting it Souls though so I guess
I'm lying and um but then of course now
it's on ps4 Xbox one X cotton XCOM -
yeah um what do you think of like Xbox
1x all this stuff that's coming out with
this what do you think of this console
shift toward almost like PC
cycles it's pretty interesting yeah I
mean I think the the basically they now
have to make the case of like why why
I'm upgrading and it's easy for me
because you know I'm like a hardware
junkie you know something like yeah that
sounds amazing like for KI that means
that I have to buy that and then I have
to buy a 4k TV because I have to
obviously I it's research for work so
yeah for me it's exciting I love I love
backwards compatibility because there's
still games that I still enjoy you know
and so it's it's really cool if they can
if they continue that then that for me
is really exciting yeah I mean it's it's
it's them responding to the market it's
in being smart you know and so yeah I
think it's great
does it change how you think at all
about like development on your end I
don't everybody we've talked to says
like you know like making it for the to
be supported on the Xbox one X is
actually pretty simple because it
actually like can benefit like working
for the s and the Xbox one etcetera and
that's rise for pro can also benefit the
slim version right on what is it does it
change how you think I mean I think is
that you you get excited at the
possibilities especially if you make
cross-platform so if you're making a PC
tunnel where you you have to take
advantage of these wide ranges of
hardware and some pretty extreme
hardware you'll always worry about like
the minimum spec is what you worry about
those so you know you got to make it
work on Xbox one and just ps4 and then
you look at you know the pro you look at
the X and you say like what extra can we
do and for us it's exciting because we
make PC games as well we already can
take advantage of something better
Hardware
yeah I just to go back to X come toward
the end we have another guest coming on
soon as but I do want to go back before
we leave um future of ex-con right like
I said it took a while for you to get
XCOM to be a reality
backup 12 it's like a decade-long
miserable thing from you know like a
cult classic back in the 90s yeah
bringing that like pretty hardcore game
to life but now you've got to you got a
few DLCs for X come to gosh ends last
gift you got enter keys children there's
more cosmetic stuff and then you've got
chosen war coming out soon yeah um do
you think you'll like leave XCOM behind
anytime soon obviously you probably
can't go into too much detail but are
you itching to kind of do something new
or is still like something you're
committed to
and this is and I get I get assets and I
can answer it honestly because I can
tell you so I've been at for access
games for 17 years over 17 years it was
my first job out of college I've been
married for 17 years I am a guy when I
like something I like it and I just
don't I'm gifted to be simple enough to
be like if I like it I don't typically
be like or I could do this other thing
I'm more like I like this I will
probably do this for the rest of my I
will probably be on this stage and 50
will be floating cuz it'll be five years
from now but wait in 50 I'll I'll be 90
I think I think I'm younger than him
okay I'll be 90 I'll be making XCOM 27
you know and I'll be up here it's great
I love it I mean I really don't I
honestly don't see myself leaving this
because because especially even when you
see the other Studios dipping their toes
in the tactical stuff like there's just
so much left to do there is so much left
to do and I like this genre games
because this this is my favorite and
this is when I play and so I play all
kinds of games but for me this is what I
always come back to so you know
sometimes you know I'll see something
people are doing like it I get blown
away by it but I really I always get
excited by like what more can I do in
this space yeah what do you think of the
overall state of the strategy like
larger strategy genre now because you
see so many things you see fire emblem
doing really rely on 3d s you see what I
said Ubisoft showed off a really weird
quirky combination of two big like
properties yeah but like but you see
other things like outside of that you
see like tactical games you see you know
like his favorite game is final fantasy
tactics is nowhere to be seen right but
and I still doubt it but surely not for
long right I mean that's what I think I
think like I think everybody's
recognizing surely not for long I mean I
think that especially as we have more
platforms to play on you know strategy
games tactical games games that are
focused around turns that give the
player a little more freedom to play
games like none of us just sit there and
or rarely do we just sit there and play
games anymore like I play games and I've
got a stream going and I'm messing
around social media like and so tackle
games any turn-based games they're great
for that and it doesn't mean that that's
all you have to play I think that people
just more open now to being like yeah
that everyone smile I'll play this I'll
have this kind of experience with games
or I'll play this different kind of game
so I don't think that I'm also dying for
Final Fantasy Tactics to come back
strong it needs to be like a medieval
like you know high fantasy type not that
we're kids we opened a book and we
time-traveled a ride still kids see
somebody's been thinking about this yeah
waiting day jump on it and what bugs me
is I've been telling him since I've
known him that it's my favorite game of
all time and he has never played it play
XCOM 2 and then we can talk right thanks
get it oh I will play Final Fantasy X
but alright so Jake Solomon when can we
play for the chosen August 29th it's out
on pc xbox one and ps4 awesome well we
really appreciate taking time out I know
you're probably busy this week no I love
I love stopping by here so thank you
guys yeah time to talk to me thank you
so much I'm looking forward to it but
yeah unfortunately we do have to bring
some in oh now I will
I believe all right thanks ollie don't
forget me all right all right cool uh
we're gonna bring on Harvey Smith talked
about death of the outsider bring them
up right now just started to uh Harvey
we've actually had you on GameSpot a lot
over the last hi guys hello nice to meet
you see you oh here we go
I didn't know that was you sit done hey
guys
I saw your badge back at the greenroom
oh really yeah forget on the couch take
it we could swap I sold it on reddit ah
I'm sure you got like 50 Cent's anyway
you just announced that death of the
outsider I think it yeah a lot of people
were kind of predicting this seems like
the time for Dishonored 2 DLC right like
a prey just came out I what are you
talking about was a total surprise
come on so tell us about it was like to
have this out in the open now yeah so um
it is called death of the outsider it
stars Billy lurk that's the thing we're
really excited about we've been waiting
years to do this she's a fan favorite
she first appeared in knife of dunwall
and the brigmore witches she's going
after her old mentor Dowd and together
they conceived this like almost
impossible assassination mission to take
down the outsider
unlike figure in our world something I
should say though is we push really hard
to make this stand alone right even if
you have not played dishonor before you
can go check out death of the outsider
it's a little shorter than a full
release it's just a few missions but it
does feature Billy lurk and she has our
own powers our own gadgets and you don't
need any prior dishonored stuff you can
buy it as a standalone thing okay yeah
the the opening trailer if I'm not
mistaken was this Megan Foster and doubt
that we're seeing yeah this is Billy
lurk so um it's a spoiler cover your
ears if you haven't played dishonored
too but there's a character named Billy
lurk from the earlier Dishonored games
who is in Dishonored to under an assumed
name right as the boat captain Megan
Foster captain of a boat that she owns
called the dreadful whale which is an
anagram for farewell doubt so she still
got some unresolved issues with her old
mentor and after the adventure with
Emily in dishonor 2 in Karnataka they go
their separate ways and she begins to
hunt for doubt yeah you're saying um
it's been of like fans have been asking
to know more about what we previously
called Megan Foster and everything
because she's such a cool character and
dishonor to and like you said knife of
dunwall and everything was this were you
always trying to explore the story was
it largely because of fans wanted to
know so much more about her you know um
there was a moment in early on and
Dishonored two's development where the
idea popped up about revisiting or
visiting this concept you know sort of
the end of the outsider and it just
percolated in the back of my head and I
would talk to various team members about
it
and all of us loved doubt as a character
where would he be 15 years later at the
end of his life an older man with
regrets Billy now that she's found her
footing at the end of dishonor 2 and she
she's got new purpose what would she do
you know she's now the actor in the in
the world she's the one that's going to
like realize this this almost impossible
assassination mission so you know at one
level dishonored is about badass
supernatural assassin moving through a
steampunk city killing off high-value
targets aristocrats and
corrupt leaders and things like that
another level it's a family story so the
whole dishonored series which we've
worked on for eight years now has had
Corvo attano as a protagonist it's had
died as a protagonists it's had emily
kaldwin and Corvo as a protagonist to
dishonor - and now Billy lerk is uh
closing out that arc for this part of
the dishonored fiction yeah I do want to
talk about how its standalone because I
think like two days ago after West
Bethesda it's like oh you I think you
can get it for $30 even if you didn't
play dishonored - yeah I was just
telling someone like talking to dingo
becau barley designer we we realized at
some point if we did this that it may be
for some percentage of the audience
their first and only foray into
Dishonored sure they might be the first
time they played the game which is a
weird concept you know so it had to work
as a as a standalone piece about this
woman who's was part of the underworld
and now has some remorse about that
wants to set things right
going after this legendary assassin
who's gone into retirement finding him
and then undertaking this mission so it
stands alone you know both in terms of
you can just buy it and play it but also
fictionally you understand the world if
you if you move into it when you get
into sort of that format when you're
offering something that's that's just
like this when normally it would just be
DLC does that does that alter maybe how
you think about this the scope of what
you're giving people in any way yeah I
mean all of those things are uh you know
like I don't know how interesting this
is to most people who play games but
like there's what you can do in the
given amount of time there's like how
much it should cost there's how much of
it should be reuse of space in Karnataka
versus new levels versus some old levels
but that have been heavily updated new
locations do you scrap all the existing
powers and movement model and start over
because it's a new protagonist like
Billy lerk has entirely different powers
then Corvo or Emily had or Dowd and you
can play through with her powers and
once you've completed the game then you
can play what we call og+ original game
plus where you can play it again with
some of Corvo and Emily's powers instead
swapped out okay
she has her own gadgets too she doesn't
use the pistol crossbow combination that
they used
she has like a voltaic gun that fires
like magnetically charged particles okay
so she's a really interesting character
but it's like where you put the work
because there's a lot of work that goes
into something like this and where you
put that you know to give value to the
people that love the series and want to
see Billy lurk want to explore Karnataka
again want to take this thing with the
outsider too it's in conclusion those
are all like highly subjective calls
that we have to make during the course
of development um so in addition to
being standalone do you think it's
something that can be an entry point for
people who haven't played this on earth
yeah absolutely yeah that's a you know
again like it occurred to us as we were
talking about it wow it is possible it's
going to be a small percentage of the
only audience I guess because most
people who are familiar with Dishonored
1 or 2 or the knife of dunwall brigmore
witches but when we made knife of
dunwall and brigmore witches it was very
popular DLC for dishonored 1 but only
people who already had this on or one
could play it you know so so I don't
know I mean I definitely think it works
and and it's exciting for some players
that might have a different reason for
for playing this they weren't interested
in the former one but they like Billy
lurk as a character more or they like
the idea of going after the outside or
more I don't know but it's definitely
playable if you have never played
dishonor before it's it's a potential
entry point to the series do you ever
have a concern when you're using like
fan favorite characters or existing
locations that somebody who maybe starts
out on this and goes back to the first
dishonored going back in time doesn't
work as well as as kind of starting here
not I didn't think about that that's an
interesting idea like I mean everything
was there's so many players out there
and we mostly hear from the people that
like Dishonored 1 and 2 or our DLC for
dishonored one wanted to knife of
dunwall brigmore witches but it is
entirely possible that someone out there
is going to play all of these in reverse
order or something so and I have no idea
what that experience would be like but
it'd be interesting I think
but like in a way this this whole thing
constantly cross-references the
political assassination of the Empress
yeah in the first game and it that's
still reverberating you know like doubt
fuels he made the world a worse place he
destabilized the world by doing that
Corvo misses the woman he loved Emily it
was her mother
Billy lurk was dad's right hand during
that time and was there that day
participated in it and doesn't want to
just feel guilty about it she wants to
do something about it so if she sees the
outsider as a concentration of power
that can be abused by people and so by
taking him out she'd removed that from
the world yeah so it's it's all in you
know the whole thing like weaves back
and forth across the time line of
roughly 15 years I'm curious it seems
like with Billy you're going for a more
gadget oriented approach or does she
have like outsider powers as well
despite the fact that she's trying to
kill him she's not marked by the
outsider her powers come from another
source okay um so again
badass supernatural assassin that's the
that's the promise that if you play the
game that's what you get but she doesn't
use blink she uses something called this
place where she can imagine being two
places at once and choose which one she
wants to go to basically chuckle which
means she can leave a marker behind that
no one else can see and later go to it
which effectively means she can go
through walls she doesn't have to have
line of sight to the place she's going
she also has a power called void strike
that she can charge up she has siblings
where she can take someone down and take
their identity so their allies speak to
her as if she were you know the person
that she's copying basically and then
she has a talisman she's carried
presumably that we say [ __ ] she was a
teenage girl given to her by her friend
Deirdre that allows her to hear the
thoughts of rats so she can if you get
near pools of rats which in Dishonored
one were very scary yeah with Billy's
talisman she can get near them it's
called rat whispers and she she gets
little clues and pieces of information
from the rats so yeah she has
supernatural powers but they come from
artifacts he has the sword that was
originally used to sacrifice the
outsider she had an arm made up of a
void
particles she has an eye called the
sliver of the eye that is a big chunk of
the eye of the divinity that existed
before the outsider to get super nerdy
on you and then she has this talisman
rat whispers so yeah she's a combination
on top of that she has the hook mine's
the magnetic thing that will you can put
on the wall and will drag people across
the room you can put multiple in
different spots and it will pull them
apart hook minds are super fun to play
with when I saw her I I instantly
thought of Kano from Mortal Kombat and I
can't unsee it very own brand just
little anecdote I'm sorry someone said
earlier you know I worked on the
original deus ex and the second deus ex
and we had a character that was pretty
popular called enna Navarre who had a
cybernetic eye that glowed red I think
and so someone said oh this reminds me
of Anna Navarro as well so I I think
once in a while the world needs a
character with an evil red glowing eyes
all right I'm gonna come back to ya but
the fact that is death of the outsider
it's called it seems pretty bold because
you think Kelly outsider how do you do
like it Dishonored 3 yeah I guess you
have to get creative
yeah or have a alternate power source
outside on fire uh I do want to talk
about like um I kind of was asking you
actually brought up Deus Ex you worked
on Deus Ex and you I know you did a QA
on System Shock yeah back it when it was
origin and yeah but I'm curious you know
you see arcane is known as kind of the
torchbearer of immersive Sims which you
know it's like the dry term for these
like emergent gameplay based you know
like just putting you in these realized
worlds where you can kind of use the
tools that you're supposed to play with
it and find different you know like
experiment differently with different
mechanics and systems I'm curious why
I've talked to you extensively about in
the past why this kind of game seems to
be making a comeback because like breath
of the wild is doing this emergent
gameplay kind of stuff Metal Gear Solid
5 even did more of that open-ended kind
of stuff whereas before it was like a
you know more linear fine-tuned stealth
game what do you think it is that's
bringing back these kind of games you
know I think there's strength in all
kinds of games recently I played what
remains of Edith Finch it's one of my
favorite games everyone should go play
that game it's amazing every now and I
pull my phone out and I play hoplite
which is an amazing little roguelike hit
mango was one of my favorite games the
year that it came out you know but I
also love horizon zero dawn
I love destiny you know there are many
different game types and reasons to play
them but I think more and more people
who grew up with games like all of us
and who have played a lot of games they
don't want to just follow a trail of
breadcrumbs they want to make decisions
they want to see surprising outcomes by
mixing and matching things so on the
indie scene you have things like
terraria you know and but even in the
the very high-end commercial market big
games with lots of heavy art and you
know that take a long time to make and
our big in scope you have people
experimenting in the Dishonored games or
the prey games you know breath of the
wild is a good example you know the
video everybody shared where he grabs
the goose and goes after the Giants and
then the giant hits the goose and all
the other geese show up an attack or
whatever I mean it was fantastic I I
played pray as they were hitting alpha
that that's a team that I didn't work
with it was an awesome but it came back
to Austin and I played to play foods
back to back about 70 hours of pray
around alpha gave him lots of notes and
the first playthrough I did all human
skills like engineer and things like
that I did no sigh powers ii when i did
only sigh powers just to really see the
difference and it took me about 70 hours
to do those two playthroughs and i swear
I told raphaël colantonio my dear friend
the creative director and Ricardo Bear
and Susan cath our producer liked her
banister calf banister now I was talking
to them and I told them the like one of
my favorite moments in a game ever in
the history of my playing games 23 years
in the industry in my top 100 moments
was a moment in prey where as the first
playthrough where I didn't use any side
powers I felt very secure because I had
a lot of engineering skill and whatever
I would find a turret I would in I would
put it in place I would upgrade it you
know I'd put it in the right position
I'd hear it in the background killing
typhoons the aliens as they came in and
so I was in this reactor room behind
this shielded glass rebooting the
reactor which creates this huge storm of
energy outside the room but I had like
four tour
it's setup and so anytime anything would
come in and just get mowed down I felt
very powerful but as I rebooted the
reactor to techno pads come into the
area responding to the disturbance and
they just have these systemic rules
where if they get near some of the
operators the the little robotic floaty
things or the turrets they dominate them
that's their nature as a they're
connected to machines and so the to
techno paths flew into the area they
flew by my turrets they sucked up all
four of the turrets so the to techno
paths are now flying around with these
turrets serving them in orbit around
them firing at me and I like that's a
situation I created through my agency
through my play of the game just a rules
interaction and it was in it worked
against me right but I still loved it
because it was like oh my god that makes
sense
I get why this happened but a holy [ __ ]
now I have to deal with these for these
two techno paths with four turrets you
know and it's it's the kind of gameplay
that I think we love you know where you
do something in the world reacts in an
interesting way it's not just going to
the next room getting the key opening
the door killing the monster going to
the next room it's it's very creatively
flexible yeah it's fascinating because
that like whether it's dishonored to or
prey as developers you have to create
these worlds where that's possible even
if you don't intend for that exact thing
to happen yeah we never conceive of half
the things that happen right um and I am
kind of like curious you know you prey
and dishonor two or very different games
right I mean there's still in the same
kind of sub-genre feel they are
different yeah right but still dishonor
two is more like stealth focused also
kind of like a discreet missions whereas
praise this yeah kind of singular
open-world if you want to call it that
yeah on the telus one space station um
what is it like seeing Arcana Austin
which is separate from your studio in
Lyon where you work on the center -
what's it like seeing them do such a
kind of a new thing that I know you said
raphaël colantonio I've been wanting to
do that for a long time yeah it's a
total pleasure because very few Studios
specialize in the kind of games that we
make and so Raph and those guys making
prey basically meant that the kind of
game that I love just emerged for me to
play at some point because I was head
down on dishonour - with the
the team in Lyon who worked very hard
many of them worked on Dishonored one
but they exclusively did Dishonored 2
with me I was living in France and now
they've done I moved back halfway
through the death of the outsider and
I've been working with them remotely so
they are also responsible for death of
the outsider so we were head down on
that and we just only play pray once in
a while to give them a little feedback
but then by the time I moved back to
Austin and they were they needed
feedback around alpha-beta
near the end of the project it was just
a sure pleasure you know to like be able
to jump in and play this kind of game
that I love so much that just seemingly
fell out of the sky to me you know so it
was really great yeah you said you know
you there's room for all different kinds
of games in the industry but do you see
this kind of a Mersenne game becoming
bigger from here on out with prey and
dishonour too and like I said these
other properties are kind of using this
kind of gameplay um what I see is that
pieces of things that work get absorbed
into other things right and so many
things that the the original pioneers of
this type of game whether you're talking
about the 1 square to time kind of games
that came out of the late 80s like
Dungeon Master or games like that or
you're talking about looking-glass who
made underworld and thief and System
Shock very important early pioneers of
this kind of you are there
first-person systems based the world is
plausible it acts and reacts the way you
would expect it to according to
expectation I just see all the pieces of
those games have been largely absorbed
even into games that are more abstract
in nature the same way RPGs used to be
this thing that we're like very esoteric
and now play Call of Duty and it has all
these RPG fans and you know so I think
it's more like that that people have
cherry-picked parts of it and it's
spread you know yeah you see some EEA
sports games are actually yeah doing RPG
stuff now like NBA live and everything
outside of that uh Madden is doing that
now it's weird to see it kind of invade
all these other genres yeah but I am I
it's it's fascinating to see how like to
go back to definitely outsider I was
talking to Jake Solomon before this um
do you ever feel like you're getting
burnt down dishonored like I know you I
know you love it cuz you've worked on it
but like is there ever this like seeing
our chaos and make prey is there do you
have this kind of itch to do something
different yeah I mean I've worked on
Dishonored games for eight years now
like from the time that raff and I
started Dishonored one in Austin was
co-developed between Leonin and Austin
um through Dishonored one knife of
dunwall brigmore witches Dishonored 2
with Emily in Corvo and now with Billy
lurk and death of the outsider and doubt
that has that has been 8 years and so I
definitely am feeling that called to uh
you know what else is out there what
what should I be exploring right now you
know but that said we love our fans we
love our players and it's been an
amazing ride it does feel like death of
the outsider is the end of a kind of an
arc not the end of Dishonored but the
end of an arc the the event around the
assassination of jessamine called one
and the Corvo Emily Dowd Billy's story
it does feel like closure to that you
know so which also gives us creative
latitude if we ever talk about new
dishonored stuff I don't know yeah I do
kinda want your take on the rest of the
comics unless you guys have any other
deftly outsider questions that seems to
be well covered yeah but yeah that was
here ok I was curious about it what you
thought of what you've seen here um I
haven't seen much actually I went to the
Bethesda showcase so I believe it or not
we don't see some of that stuff so I had
never seen the Wolfenstein trailer which
blew me away I had never seen the evil
within with the amazing cover of the
Duran Duran song ordinary world yep way
back but I was blown away by it stuff
it's very cool I've been part of a
publisher off and on to my 23-year
career but I have to say this is the
first time you just look around at all
the other studios and you're just like
intimidated humbled amazed that the
things your your peers are working on
whether it's the Fallout games or
it elderscrolls bringing more win to the
MMO the guys that machine game work
working out machine games working on
Wolfenstein it's all cool and we got
lots of feedback from them on death of
the outsider and Billy lark is a
character but that said also walking
around I'm aware of what's here or what
people are talking about and I you
mentioned Jake solemn and like I'm super
excited about the new x-column stuff I
hope that's really good I want to play
that there's new content coming for
horizon zero dawn I think so excited
about that Tacoma is something I'm
watching because I love gone home and
the guys that worked on that so I mean
it's overwhelming because especially
when you like you guys you're working
well your interview is probably more
transversal of everything mind is much
more head down talking about Bill Alert
and doubt and to the outsider so a lot
of it for me is watching the videos
later when I go back to the hotel room
and I'm just wiped out and exhausted I'm
in a bathrobe and I'm watching
that's my evening by the way but yeah
that sounds like that's not right um
what about the Xbox one X I guess that's
like a thing I just I've kind of been
asking anytime I get the chance to chat
with a developer this week I'm asking
what they kind of think of this new
console cycle if you want to call it
that's moving toward more like the PC
side of things from your perspective as
developer does that change how you think
about development at all you know I have
a developer's view of that in that more
power is always better yeah but at the
same time it's also requires more
support and backwards support and all
that it's a little more complicated but
I think in general we'll see we'll see
how the players respond to it but I'm
generally very optimistic about it yeah
like all the things that are being
brought to it you know I know I'll get
one I'm excited you know I have a ps4 at
home also and I have a high-end PC you
know so it's it's all good and I haven't
bought a switch yet but I want to buy a
switch you know so but I'm probably
anomalous in that I don't I don't feel
compelled to pick one and and go with it
you know I'm always straddling two or
three last time for me it was probably
PC iPhone and
xbox360 and this time I've spent a lot
of time on my ps4 my PC yeah I actually
been disappointed with the mobile games
lately like it feels like we went
through a period of time where mobile
games are really exciting yeah and
nothing's really caught my attention
lately I don't know maybe maybe that'll
change soon but yeah you mentioned like
hitman go and like was it learning off
mark rothko was great too but since then
there hasn't been yeah you're right now
I think about there hasn't really been
like a discoverability is such a
challenge on mobile yeah there you go
I mean like it's great that everybody
more and more people can make games
tools are more freeform everything's out
there you can just put it up or whatever
but it doesn't help anybody if it's just
instantly lost in a massive sea of
uncured contents or whatever you know so
I'm glad that's not my problem to solve
that sounds like a very hard problem but
yeah I don't to ask well we're actually
it's kind of like we're on a stream
right now and Jake Saunders saying
whenever he's playing a game he almost
always has a stream up and he's looking
his phone and everything and then with
game the kind of games you make there's
a reward experimentation and you find
out things that you could do like you
mentioned the chicken and breath of a
wild of chucko chucko where they're
called uh like finding things like that
that you didn't know could happen just
like it's funny that you know the kind
of games you make seem almost
tailor-made for like these youtube
videos that come out or like the
streamer to find something crazy excited
like does that affect how you see your
games in the aftermath like I know I was
talking to you before like what it's
like to see people playing Dishonored on
YouTube like the next day and like doing
things that you didn't even consider
yeah I mean that phenomenon is really
fantastic and I've told the story before
about how at the end of Dishonored one
long before death of the outsider and
the bill ealer conclusion and all that
just we had just finished Dishonored one
and we were working on a knife of
dunwall or something I think or a patch
actually was earlier than that we ran a
patch or something and riptides is one
of the early streamers that we watched
ripped IPO W I don't remember what his
exact handle is but he was playing the
very end of the game and you know he
played the entire game and every day
we'd walk through the the break area and
like stop at the monitor and look oh
he's he's third of the way through the
game always half of the way through the
name and by the time you get to the
final mission the end the whole team was
gathered in this break room around this
monitor watching talking and I'll never
forget he like Admiral Havelock had
Emily it was like the hiya chaos ending
or whatever and was threatening to drop
her off the tower and he was like I in
my memory it's probably wrong but in my
memory was eating or something and he
was like oh yeah sure you're gonna drop
the little girl off the tower video game
and then she goes and Falls her doom you
know and he was just like what and so we
all had this amazing reaction to
watching somebody else work their way
through the gameplay and through the
story and stuff it's very gratifying in
a way that I wouldn't have anticipated
and what a way to get feedback right
like most honest feedback possible yeah
yeah exactly and not only what they're
saying but what people in the comments
are saying is that do you take that too
into account when you go into something
like death of the outsider yeah I mean
not not too much because uh for at least
this arc of Dishonored games we pretty
much have a vision for them we know that
people play them you know we have
several people who play dishonored in
the most stealthy way possible and they
comment as they're playing and they try
all those little clever things and other
dishonored fans are watching them and
something goes wrong and it all goes
crazy violence or whatever we anticipate
that for the the bili lurk death of the
outsider chapter as well but as yet we
haven't really like moved the game to
that to something that's more supportive
of that model you know we've we've been
pretty focused on this is the kind of
game we make it's all about being a
badass supernatural assassin jumping
rooftop to rooftop killing off corrupt
aristocrats sneaking past guards trying
to be careful but then when things go
wrong going super violent you know yes
that's pretty much like what our players
love about the dishonored games that in
the rich world you know the work we do
layers and layers of environmental
storytelling in the worlds a very
plausible complete world even though
it's a fantasy world so yeah so I do
hope death of the outsider is a an entry
point for some people who haven't played
and I also hope that the people who have
been with us this eight year ride liked
it as well they liked the conclusion
that we
come - yeah - be kind of a geek quick
about like the history of this kind of
game you know like you can look at
dishonored as an homage to thief almost
and then you can look at praised no maje
the system shock and then even if you
want to go back before you write arcane
you know when they open with ArcSight
alice is kind of an homage to all Ultima
Underworld yeah yeah do you see anything
else in the past you would like to see
come back whether it's from your from
someone else well I'm really excited
about the new Metro game yeah and so you
know there's always been like a vibe
there a tone that I've that I found
appealing because it's from a culture
outside my own or whatever right stalker
originally was like kind of magical for
some of us so yeah I mean there's also
terranova a game nobody remembers what
it was like
based on the Wing Commander structure of
play but you played a you know a Power
Suit power armor character in a sci-fi
setting and some of the mission design
behind that was really really amazing
for its time awesome uh yeah so we're
just gonna close it out and go back up
to our stage momentarily but last
question I guess like $30.00 death the
outsider when can we play it $29.99
actually oh sorry
hahaha oh you're professional I'm tired
it's available definitely outsider
starring Billy lurk standalone is
available September 15 okay cool
well Harvey thanks so much for coming on
stage we've closed it out soon or not
quickly I've meant to do this earlier in
the show but if you watch the lobby you
know we do giveaways this one's actually
kind of huge if you follow a GameSpot on
Twitter you can go we have a link on the
site doing LG and Newegg
are teaming up to it's like an entire
gaming prize pack it's a 34 inch ultra
wide HD curved led gaming monitor as
well as a mechanical gaming keyboard
stereo gaming headset gaming mice $50
Newegg gift card we're gonna choose one
winner tonight and another one tomorrow
night so you can go to GameSpot if you
don't follow us on Twitter do that and
then you can go check that out but yeah
we're gonna go back up the state
upstairs but Harvey thank you so much
for job thank you guys
have a good rest of the show and thanks
for talking about death The Outsider we
always yeah and everybody thank you so
much for joining here we really
appreciate it we appreciate seeing some
familiar facing to stream and everything
we're gonna throw it back upstairs to
the stage for another demo throughout
the day but stay tuned to game spot see
you there
[Music]
you
you